[Musique]
ici affinera temps ci pour go et nous
sommes en pleine période d'élection dans
un pays qui a été militairement
appliquée dans 98% des pays du monde est
envahie 84 et 193 pays que compte l'onu
à suivre
trump va-t-il perdre l'élection
présidentielle à cause du coc vide qui a
fait des centaines de milliers de morts
aux etats unis
nous nous rendons à la maison blanche
pour parler avec l'un des deux seuls
hommes que le président semble écouter
au sujet de la pandémie
le conseiller spécial de donald trump
sur le coronavirus le professeur scott
atlas nous explique pourquoi le
confinement les tests de masse et les
masques ne fonctionne pas tout cela dans
notre émission mais tout d'abord
l'élection présidentielle va avoir un
impact sur le monde entier alors que
l'épidémie mondiale de coronavirus
poursuit et continue de faire des
victimes
tournons nous vers la maison blanche
pour parler avec l'un des conseillers de
donald trump sur le corps navires us le
professeur scott atlas merci infiniment
scott d'être là avec nous comment
interprétez vous les chiffres à quel
point la situation avec le coronavirus
et elle mauvaise aux états unis je
suppose que vous savez que les médias
traditionnels qui penche du côté des
démocrates disent que le coronavirus
pourrait mettre un terme à la présidence
de trump et bien merci beaucoup de me
recevoir cette pandémie et meurtrière
cela ne fait aucun doute
on a eu en gros plus de 230 mille morts
à cause du virus
beaucoup de pertes à cause de la
politique de confinement c'est tragique
il n'y a aucun doute là dessus mais si
vous voulez savoir ce qui se passe en ce
moment je pense qu'il ya une distorsion
qui a été récurrentes dans la manière de
traiter cela dans les médias c'est à
dire qu'il ya cette obsession de se
focaliser sur le nombre de cas ici alors
qu'on a des raisons d'être prudemment
optimistes
plutôt que d'avoir peur il est très
important que les gens comprennent
ces raisons d'abord le nombre de cas ne
constituent pas les données les plus
importantes
ce qui est important est de comprendre
que la majorité de ces cas sont des gens
présentant moins de risques en bonne
santé
nous faisons du bon boulot dans la
protection des personnes âgées et les
populations à risque
le virus n'est vraiment mortel que pour
les personnes âgées et les populations à
risque ce que je dis ce n'est pas que
personne n'en meurt mais que le risque
pour les jeunes d'être gravement malade
est très faible
ce sont les chiffres vous savez 99,97 %
des gens qui ont entre 0 et 18 ans vont
bien
donc il y a des choses positives on voit
que le taux de mortalité est non
seulement plus faibles que ce à quoi on
s'attendait au début mais en plus il
décroît en fonction de la tranche d'âge
et quand je regarde les données et pas
seulement pour ceux qui ont plus de 85
ans mais aussi de 75 à 84 de 64 à 74 etc
etc
les taux de mortalité décline donc même
s'il tombe malade
ils ont moins de chances de mourir le
taux de mortalité dans les hôpitaux est
deux fois moins important de ce qu'il
était au plus fort de l'épidémie
la durée d'hospitalisation a diminué
d'un tiers de ce qu'elle était au plus
fort de l'épidémie
nous n'avons pas de problème même si
occasionnellement un hôpital peut être
débordé mais l'administration est mieux
préparé et mobilise ressources
lee
personnel pour éviter l'engorgement des
hôpitaux il n'y a d'ailleurs pas eu aux
etats-unis le moindre patients
nécessitant un respirateur qui
n'auraient pas été mis sous respirateur
pas le moindre donc on voit beaucoup de
cas mais on ne voit pas une explosion de
la mortalité des gens meurent
nous ne sous-estimons pas du tout les
choses
nous travaillons toujours plus pour
protéger les personnes âgées et les
personnes qui pourraient en mourir
et vous savez je suis personnellement
impliqué là dedans et je m'assure qu'on
ne fait pas que coucher ses politiques
sur le papier mais qu'on les met bien en
oeuvre ce qu'a fait l'administration
s'est donné la priorité aux équipements
de protection dans les établissements de
soins pour personnes âgées aux tests en
15 minutes pour éviter les cas
d'infection par le personnel de ces
maisons de retraite que nous testons
massivement nous allons dans les centres
où les personnes âgées
ok il y a plein de choses comme ça
plein de médicaments sont en train
d'être mis au point on attend sous peu
une autorisation d'utilisation d'urgence
pour un médicament enverra il y a
beaucoup de progrès je comprends par là
pourquoi votre président semble si
optimiste durant sa compagne at il vu
l'étude de l'université de washington
selon laquelle on en sera à cinq cent
mille morts en février
cela semble contredire l'absence de
corrélation selon vous entre le nombre
de cas et la mortalité
prenez le modèle de l'institut de
statistiques sur la santé publique
c'est un peu absurde de regarder sur le
modèle à l'heure actuelle certaines
choses dans ce modèle
je vais vous donner un exemple si vous
vous penchez sur la littérature
académique d'épidémiologistes qui ont
étudié ce modèle
sur 24 heures dans les prévisions de
mortalité état par état
il était en dehors de leurs intervalles
de confiance plus de 70% du temps il est
absurde de croire que ce modèle va
prévoir combien de gens vont mourir s'il
porte un masque ou non tous ceux qui à
l'heure actuelle se focalise sur ces
modèles
non vraiment tiré aucune leçon du passé
et d'ailleurs nous avons énormément de
données je ne comprends pas cette
fixation chez certaines personnes pour
ses modèles qui veulent faire sensation
nous avons des modèles nous savons
qu'ils présentent des risques
nous savons qu'ils n'en présente pas à
nous savons comment instaurer pour eux
une distanciation sociale et les
protégés sur le plan hygiénique
il est raisonnable de porter un masque
si ce sont des personnes à risque ou si
vous l'êtes
c'est le genre de choses que nous
faisons il y à du progrès avec les
médicaments il y à du progrès sur
différentes choses et pourtant les gens
parlent de modèle je ne comprends pas
[Musique]
vous avez de toute évidence conseillé à
trump de ne pas prendre ce modèle en
compte
vous êtes désormais en faveur du port du
masque auparavant et là on touche à
l'information pendant la pandémie
je crois savoir que twitter a supprimé
un de vos tweets au sujet du masque donc
il y à deux questions
êtes vous en faveur du masque et il n'y
a eu aucun changement dans mes
convictions ou dans celle du président
concernant les masques aucun ce qui a
été supprimé
laissez-moi rappelé la politique que je
lui ai conseillé et qu'il a mentionné
des dizaines et des dizaines de fois
porter un masque
quand vous ne pouvez pas respecté les
distances iations sociale en particulier
quand vous êtes une personne à risque ou
que vous êtes proche d'une personne à
risque
c'est une politique raisonnable ce qui
n'est pas raisonnable ce qui est
irrationnelle et je vais vous dire ce
qui a été supprimé sur twitter il est
irrationnel de penser qu'il faut avoir
son masque si on est au milieu du désert
ou dans sa voiture en train de cons
tout seul ou en train de conduire seul
dans un parc cela n'est pas rationnel il
n'y a pas besoin d'être un scientifique
pour comprendre que cette absurde que
c'est le résultat de la peur distillée
par ceux qui insistent sur ce type de
politique sans analyser les données et
les études
quant à ce qui a été supprimé de twitter
j'étais en train de tweets et que
l'utilisation généralisée par toute la
population du masque ne marche pas au
regard des données empiriques que nous
avons c'est la première chose j'ai fait
la liste los angeles miami hawaï
l'alabama l'espagne la france le royaume
uni et israël tous les endroits où ils
ont imposé le port du masque à toute la
population ont alors vu le nombre de cas
explose et se sont défaits ce n'est pas
contestable
est-ce que je peux juste ok allez
laissez moi terminer vous m'avez demandé
bien sûr la deuxième partie de ce tweet
qui a été supprimée ne contenait aucun
commentaire de ma part mais seulement
des citations de l' oms du professeur
hannigan du centre d'oxford avec la
médecine fondée sur des données
probantes
l'étude du centre de contrôle et de
prévention des maladies
c'était des citations aucunement une
opinion mais des faits qui vont à
l'encontre de croyance se voient
supprimer de twitter je pense que la
suppression de ce tweet est un plus gros
problème
nous vivons dans un monde où désormais
pour quelques raisons que ce soit
l'information qui contredit ce que des
gens veulent croire vous êtes vous
plaint auprès de twitter car vous avez
une constitution qui garantit la liberté
de parole aux états unis la constitution
est menacée
c'est très dangereux mais qu'est ce
qu'ils vous ont dit qu'est ce qu'ils ont
dit ok comment twitter marche
ils ont supprimé mon tweet ils ont
bloqué mon compte donc je vois qu'on
peut faire appel
en appuyant sur un bouton de problème
s'il ne vous donne pas beaucoup de place
pour écrire mais bon j'ai fait cela
ensuite j'ai attendu six heures et je me
suis dit que mon compte étant bloquée il
était évident que le tweet avaient été
supprimés de toute évidence ils peuvent
supprimer
j'ai appuyé sur ce bouton et j'ai dû
attendre 12 heures pour que mon compte
soit rétablie à ceux ci peuvent
supprimer le tweet d'un conseiller de la
maison blanche c'est quelque chose me
dit oui à quel point est politisé la
réponse à cette pandémie
vous avez parlé des classes ouvrières et
de l'impact du confinement et c est ce
que vous pensez que ce qu'on appelle les
médias traditionnels comprennent votre
préoccupation à l'égard des classes
ouvrières des états unis eh bien je
suppose que la classe ouvrière a
conscience de ses propres préoccupations
les confinements resteront célèbres
comme un exemple de magistrales bourde
de politiques publiques décidées par des
gens qui ont refusé d'accepter avoir
tort ne savaient pas qu'ils avaient tort
et s'en fichait et sont devenus obsédés
par l'idée de supprimer à tout prix tous
les cas et ce prix est gigantesque
ce qui a lieu ici c'est que c'est
indéniable les confinements tue les gens
mais ils n'ont pas beaucoup d'impact
et quand je parle de confinement je ne
parle pas de voir tout le monde figé
dans le temps et dans l'espace tout seul
dans sa chambre car il est facile de
dire on n'est pas pour le confinement
mais ce qu'ils veulent faire c'est
tester des gens asymptomatiques isoler
les gens de leur travail de leur famille
pour 14 jours
fermer les écoles fermer les magasins
c'est un confinement et on voit ce que
les confinements ont comme impact sur
les gens même pour moi d'accord pour
ceux qui ont un bon boulot qui sont de
la classe supérieure plutôt aisée la
classe politique
la classe des médias ces gens là ne sont
pas touchés parce qu'ils ont toujours
leur travail alors oui à voir ses
enfants dans les jambes
ce n'est pas pratique mais ça ça ça
n'est pas la même chose que pour les
classes moyennes et inférieures d'un
point de vue socio économique où les
emplois disparaissent suicides explose
la consommation de drogues explose
nous sommes en train de faire une
génération de névrosés en forçant les
enfants à porter des masques et être à
deux mètres de leurs amis ou même ne pas
aller à l'école
vous savez aux états unis on voit que
pour la génération des 18 24 ans 24 à
25% d'entre eux ont pensé à se suicider
en juin à cause du confinement
c'est une immense tragédie
il ya de plus en plus de données et j'ai
écrit à ce sujet en avril ou mai bien
avant que je vienne ici et je n'étais
pas le grand méchant de la planète en
écrivant ça mais quand vous venez ici et
que vous vous tenez à côté du président
pour essayer d'aider votre pays dans un
contexte de crise mondiale
vous devez être détruits par les médias
aux états unis c'est une triste
constatation sur l'amérique ils sont
hystériques sur ce sujet mais le fait
est que les autorités sanitaires ont
échoué et tuent des gens avec leur
politique terrifiante de confinement il
tue littéralement des gens professeur je
vous arrête là nous retrouvons scott
atlas après cette pause
[Musique]
de retour dans going down avec le
professeur scott atlas de l'équipe de
gestion du coronavirus de la maison
blanche
vous êtes de toute évidence excité à
l'idée de voir de potentiel remède
contre le coc vide et votre président a
parlé de contrôler le prix des
médicaments s'ils devaient être ré alors
que les grands groupes pharmaceutiques
finances la compagne de joe biden
n'est-il pas un peu délicat pour le
président trump de s'en prendre aux
profits des grands groupes
pharmaceutiques
à quelques jours de l'élection je pense
que ce qu'il fait c'est s'en prendre à
une asymétrie est un paradoxe
les gens paient pour leurs médicaments
ici aux etats unis
je pense qu'il faut regarder les
politiques qu'il a mis en oeuvre et où
il vient parce que pour ce qui est de la
fixation des prix des médicaments aux
états unis pour la première fois en
plusieurs décennies
les prix ont baissé l'indicé des prix à
la consommation dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique a baissé et ça n'avait
pas eu lieu depuis des décennies je n'ai
historiquement pas vu cela en plusieurs
décennies
c'est la première fois cela vient d'une
concurrence accrue d'une plus grande
dérégulation qui ont fait les prix
s'adapter à celui qui paye qui dans ce
cas est le patient avec la transparence
et bien les prix baissent ce qu'ils
essaient de faire c'est de faire baisser
les prix des médicaments en disant ok
peut-être que les prix devraient être
les mêmes que dans le reste du monde
donc on verra ce qu'il se passera avec
les prix dans le reste du monde
ce n'est pas encore très clair on verra
mais je pense qu'il se bat ici pour les
consommateurs à quoi nous étions en
train de parler de classe il y a un
instant les chèques de soutien sujets
qui intéressera les américains qui
regardent cette émission
voyez-vous une opposition démocrates au
congrès encore une fois c'est une
question de santé publique à cause du
coronavirus qui mènerait à
l'impossibilité de mettre en place des
chèques de soutien
il est difficile de nier que tout cela
est politique
nous sommes en plein dans une élection
difficile comme chacun 7 mai il est
triste de voir que je ne suis pas un
politique je ne m'intéresse pas à la
politique en fait j'ai même un certain
dégoût de la politique qui s'est
renforcé pendant toute cette période
mais quand vous voyez des politiciens
faire barrage à des choses qui devraient
normalement considérées comme
importantes importante pour les
consommateurs ou pour les individus
qu'ils représentent
faire barrage pour des raisons
politiques et écoeurant c'est tragique
je ne sais même pas quoi ajouter à cela
parlons un peu de stratégie
pourquoi un pays comme la corée du sud
soutenue par les états unis avec un
capital c ou le plus grande que chicago
ou londres n'a que 460 morts des as
oh il y a plein de raisons à cela et je
pense qu'il est très naïf de tirer des
conclusions générales concernant les
différences entre les pays de ce point
de vue mais pour la corée du sud et les
autres pays asiatiques
il y a des raisons de croire que
beaucoup de pays asiatiques ont été
moins touchés par le sar ce 2 parce
qu'ils ont une expérience biologique
bien plus développée sur ce genre de
virus que ce soit le sarm 1 que ce soit
d'autre coronavirus il suffit de voir
les données de singapour
ils ont pris des échantillons de sang de
gens ayant été infectées par le sarm 1
il y a dix sept ans et quand vous lisez
cette étude on voit une réponse
cellulaire très forte face à ce virus 17
ans plus tard et il y a beaucoup de
raisons de croire qu'il y à une
protection au niveau du système
immunitaire
mais il ya beaucoup de différences entre
les populations
il est délicat de commencer à comparer
les pays et d'ensuite pointé du doigt
quelque chose la seule chose à faire est
d'évaluer la surmortalité plus que le
taux de mortalité
parce que le taux de mortalité relève de
comment vous caractérisez ces morts et
aux états unis
nous n'avons pas à avoir un test positif
au que vite pour catégoriser un mort
comme lié aux qu'ovide son estampille
mort du co vide tout moore associé au
coronavirus et il n'y a rien que le
président ou votre équipe à la maison
blanche aurait pu faire pour réécrire
les règles d'établissement des
certificats de décès théâtre
vous savez l'établissement des
certificats de décès aux états unis
relève bien plus de l'arc de la science
c'est aux médecins de déterminer la
cause
mais je voudrais vous corrigez ici ce
n'est pas mon équipe j'en prends note
que pensez vous de votre collègue le
docteur anthony fauci qui vous a
qualifié d' outsider disant même se
faire du souci pour vous pourquoi dire
une chose pareille je ne sais pas je ne
peux pas parler à la place du dr fochi
mais je peux dire cela je suis fier
d'être un outsider en particulier
lorsqu'on voit que les insider ont tout
faux donc je n'ai pas peur d'aller
contre le vent quand je sais que j'ai
raison et c'est très important
nettement plus diffamatoire gates
qu'avez vous ressenti quand il vous a
qualifié de ce doux experts et je dois
souligner que ces gates qui financent
tous ses essais sur les vaccins eh bien
je n'étais même pas au courant et il a
fallu que quelqu'un me le disent parce
que pour être tout à fait honnête je me
fiche complètement de ce que quelqu'un
comme bill gates peut dire être riche
n'implique en rien à voir des expertises
c'est la première chose la seconde est
que je me sens bien vis-à-vis de ma
propre expertise de mon propre cv je
travaille dans la santé publique depuis
15 ans j'ai aussi 25 ans d'expériences
médicales au plus haut niveau académique
disons les choses ainsi ce que j'ai
proposée se base sur la science je le
dis au moins depuis le mois de mars et
je le disais chez moi dès février et je
les écris à partir de mars
je n'ai rien dit de faux et ça a été
validée aujourd'hui par plus de 11000
épidémiologistes de haut niveau et ceux
qui ont signé la déclaration de great
barrington qui en gros est en accord
avec la plupart des choses que j'ai
dites protéger les gens à risque éviter
l'encombrement des hôpitaux et les dotés
en ressources afin que les gens
bénéficient de soins mais laissez les
écoles les entreprises les
société ouverte c'est une politique qui
se basant sur les données
je parle avec les meilleurs
épidémiologistes quasiment tous les
jours depuis sept ou huit mois je ne
suis pas en train de joindre mais quand
des gens entendent des choses qu'ils ne
veulent pas croire au lieu de changer
d'arguments au lieu d'user d'arguments
qui serait défait les gens ignorants et
tout simplement peu sûrs de leurs
propres connaissances se lance dans les
attaques ad hominem et vraiment je n'ai
pas de temps pour ça je suis occupé ici
à faire une chose essayer de sauver des
vies du peuple américain
c'est mon but et je sais de quoi je
parle je suis conseiller par des experts
très variés venant de divers horizons et
j'essaie de conseiller le président sur
les bonnes politiques à prendre de toute
évidence le ms n'est pas d'accord avec
la déclaration de great barrington
et comme vous dites bill gates a
définitivement beaucoup d'argent et
certainement beaucoup de pouvoir
pourquoi pensez-vous qu'il y à des
luttes au sein du comité à londres elles
ont lieu en public sa bd géants de
l'industrie critique les experts des
comités gouvernementaux
je ne pense pas que ça ait lieu ailleurs
en europe
est-ce que ça n'est pas lié à la
politique américaine oui je pense que
vous savez je connaisse une et ragoût
pta au royaume uni elle est l'une des
plus grandes épidémiologistes et
infectiologie sts du monde et elle était
pas mal critiqués mais je dirais cela
les états unis sont les états unis il y
a deux bons aspects les gens sont plus
directs mais le pays des rails sa cause
de cette hystérie qui a été alimenté par
ses experts en santé publique
ils ont non seulement eu tort mais en
plus sans doute été intéressés par leur
image publique que par autre chose il
faut regarder les données selon moi
une partie de la gouvernance est d'être
sûr qu'on comprend de quoi on parle
s'assurer que les gens comprennent que
vous comprenez et que vous prenez des
politiques basées sur le bon sens et la
rationalité
au lieu de vous stressez tous les deux
jours quant à ce qu'on ne sait pas où
est ce qu'on devrait être en train de
faire et dire ce qu'on sait parce qu'on
sait pas mal de choses ici l'hystérie
est alimenté par les hyperboles sur les
réseaux sociaux
c'est peut-être un aspect culturel
américain mais il est indéniable que
nous nous trouvons à un moment de cette
élection où les gens sont très polarisée
cela aggrave clairement les choses et
j'espère si je peux me permettre d'être
optimiste sur un point et que les choses
seront un peu plus rationnel
une fois que l'élection aura eu lieu je
n'ai pas de grands espoirs mais tout de
même
ok le président obama a été joe biden
vous l'avez peut-être entendu dire que
ce dernier avait une équipe pour gérer
la pandémie mais qu'elle a été détruite
par l'administration trump pensez vous
que les plus de 200000 morts aux etats
unis sont une conséquence de la décision
d'abolir le département pour la sécurité
sanitaire et biologiques du conseil
national de sécurité
c'est complètement faux de dire qu'il y
avait une très bonne équipe pour
répondre à cette pandémie
c'est totalement faux un point c'est
tout je sais ce qu'il y avait ici avant
que tout ça ne commence la deuxième
chose c'est que nous avons là une
maladie mortelle pour les gens à risque
il n'y a pas de doute là dessus
c'est un mensonge et ne et déraisonnable
que de dire qu'il n'y aurait pas dû
avoir d'autres morts que ceux liés à la
compétence ou à des délais quelconque
l'administration a fait beaucoup
alors qu'elle était aveugle sans stock
qui auraient été générés par la
précédente administration
mobiliser toutes ses ressources des
milliards de dollars en équipements de
protection accélérer la production de
médicaments accélérer la production des
vaccins
et tout cela en un temps record vous
savez oui beaucoup de gens sont morts
est d'ailleurs plus de 230 3000 morts
entre eau sous la responsabilité de jean
dont vous connaissez les noms avant même
que je n'arrive ici si vous voulez
parler de ça mais en gros le fait est
qu'il y a une maladie mortelle et les
estimations sont que si vous voulez
suivre ces modèles que vous citez 2,2
millions de personnes devraient en
mourir aux états unis on ne peut pas
changer le jeu soyons raisonnables
essayons de comprendre que beaucoup a
été accompli et avec succès ce qui n'est
pas une consolation pour ceux qui ont
perdu des proches
je connais des gens qui en sont morts
moi même c'est très triste
il n'y a aucun doute là dessus personne
ne dit le contraire mais nous faisons
face à une maladie mortelle
on s'en sortira il faut être rationnel
faire preuve de bon sens et comprendre
que la vie doit continuer que la vie
continuera et que sauver des vies juste
pour finir brièvement vous dites ne pas
être un politique
ce qui n'a pas empêché les candidats de
parler de vous qu'est ce que serait une
présidence baden baden a dit que pas le
moindre médecin sérieux sur la planète
nous considérait que vos actions avait
un sens qu'est-ce que cela dit d'une
potentielle présidence by donne dans la
lutte contre le corps un virus quelqu'un
qui s'exprimeraient comme ça on ne sait
pas de quoi il parle
sacrement perturbé car les politiques
que j'ai préconisé
elles ont été validées par onze mille
épidémiologistes et médecins dans la
déclaration
et cela inclut des gens de harvard
stanford oxford et d'autres institutions
de haut niveau je pense que ce genre de
commentaire est très curieux et je ne
sais quoi vous dire à part que c'est
complètement fou professeur scott atlas
merci merci
je
[Musique]